[Music]
if you watch joe biden a lot you know
sometimes it'd be hard to understand
what he is saying often joe biden
himself doesn't seem to know what he's
saying
but we decided to crack the code so like
the football coaches we are
at heart we turn to the tape it turns
out when you assemble the footage from
joe biden's speeches over the years
a spine comes into view a consistent
message
emerges that message is that joe biden
is the best person who's ever lived he
is solely responsible for
everything good in this world watch
i'm the guy after 9 11 said we will
follow bin laden to the gates of hell if
we have to to get him
i'm the guy that helped bail out the
automobile industry what'd you do
buddy i'm the guy that managed the 830
billion dollars i'm the guy only guy
that's ever beaten them nationally i've
beaten him three times
i'm the guy that got a bipartisan
agreement i'm the guy that ran
the recovery act i'm the guy that set up
drug courts
i'm the guy that got sent up to the hill
i'm the guy that helped put together the
iran deal
i'm the guy that got the brady bill
passed i'm the guy that asked for the
the cdc to keep detailed reports
obviously i think i'm the guy
but that's for you to decide
come on man i'm the guy
i'm the guy i'm the guy they set up to
the hill i'm the guy
on tuesday night joe biden will be
debating
despite our predictions turns out he's
actually going to do what it looks like
one thing we know he'll be the guy well
last